what are you doing me actress Christian
ritter starred in the TV series Gilmore
Girls that's more than ten years ago Wow
Ritter made her mark on Hollywood with
roles and hit shows like Veronica Mars
and Breaking Bad remember breaking back
what was your character's name Jane Jane
she was the girlfriend had issues and in
movies including confessions of a
shopaholic she stars now as a superhero
and private investigator in the Netflix
series Marvel's Jessica Jones this
season she runs into a little bit of
trouble with police when she's arrested
for murder
Trish already gave a statement they have
no proof they believe that you know
things that you're not telling them yeah
it's called professional discretion well
they will call it obstruction of justice
it's a probation violation and I don't
put me away for 18 months unless you
tell them what you know a poodle doesn't
show its belly to a pitbull if it
doesn't want to get its guts ripped out
and you're the poodle or they will lump
me in with that maniac and they will
start pinning every unsolved crime on me
because that's what they do not that you
have a chip on your shoulder just fix
this don't snap at me if she was smart
she would not snap at you because we
know you got superpowers Krysten Ritter
so let's talk about the end of last
season because you end up killing the
your tormentor yeah killing him in a
very violent way Yeah right to his face
yeah his neck has a last resort as of
last resort and how did that feel to you
because he had been tormenting you all
season and now you're coming into the
new season but talk about what that was
like for you to finally say okay I got
you it was really it was really exciting
it was exciting moment for the character
it was who was triumphant it was her
being strong I remember when I got the
episode script when that happened I
chaired I was because it needed to
happen it was really a difficult journey
for Jessica to get to that point yeah
she doesn't want to be a murderer yeah
but that was really the only option for
her but now she's dealing with the
aftermath of that yeah wondering if you
can if you have conflict about the power
that you have yeah Jessica has a lot of
contempt for the powers that she has she
is a girl that is marked by by trauma
she Hugh struggles she has PTSD she
drinks too much she hardly hardly gets
by and the fact that she has this powers
has these powers and this attention on
her kind of goes against everything
everything that she is can I ask you
about the purple man the your nemesis he
used to say smile yeah what did that
mean that was really powerful it was
really powerful and it was so
interesting because around the time that
we were making that show member that
video came out of the woman walking
around Manhattan and everyone being like
smile smile and it was just so such a
way that it kind of didn't make her feel
great and then our show came out and
used that message and it was like you
know how we sort of recap time consent
and and it took away her voice telling
her to smile and so in the end in the
final moment when she snaps his neck she
says to him smile yeah you're known for
your superpower yeah so do people come
up to you I was reading that people
actually come up to you and say go ahead
hit me Kristen hit me arm-wrestle armor
is that true yeah it's a thing you know
it happens at men and women men men I've
never had a woman yet you know come up
to me and ask me to punch them but a lot
of times you know we go to conventions
or common Comic Cons and things like
that to promote the show and a lot of
men ask me to either arm-wrestle them or
punch them what do you do I just go for
it you know you got to give the fans
what they want yeah you know my fans
keep me employed they want me to punch
them fight and do female viewers say you
know that that your character makes them
feel better about some of the trauma
that happened a lot and I think that's
been one of the most moving experiences
of this whole job I'm in addition to it
being a great acting part I've had women
come up to me and say that they feel
represented it's made them feel better
about what they've been through in their
own lives and then just simply seeing a
badass female character like this has
meant a lot to a lot of women and men so
so that's something that's been really
exciting for me
and it makes me want to work
even harder and throw my full self into
the role is that why we all like comic
book stories and and we're heroes
superheroes I think that what our show
does and what Marvel does well is they
they kind of go underneath the superhero
powers you know the they've let you fall
in love with the person underneath of
all of that and you root for them um you
know Joe Quesada at Marvel talks about
how you don't just like to talk about
the guy in the suit it's the guy under
the suit and I think that's what Jessica
Jones does specifically it's such a
personal story and and we really get
into her her psychological journey
that's my the backstory and the origin
story are always so important yeah can
we talk about the girl under your suit
sure much more fun than Joe so I love
that you grew up in a farm on a farm in
central Pennsylvania yeah northeastern
Pennsylvania about three and a half
hours on the bus
Jordan George I love you covered at the
mall and I was discovered at 3:00 you at
casual corner limited Express what I
think the pretzel plays what were you
doing I think the pretzel place was near
I think I may have been in front of
somebody came up to you and said what
there was a scout from Elite Model
Management which I had heard of which is
really agency yeah he came up to me and
my mom and asked if I if we had ever
thought about modeling and I think my
mom and I looked at each other like no
so so that was a sort of how I got my
foot in the door as a teenager and then
from there I Lily padded into
commercials and actually you play a
badass character but guys she also knit
I know I can't imagine you said because
that's such an Anna thing to me I know
but I'm making it cool yes right yeah
you know it's a way it's a great way for
me to have balance especially when I'm
playing a dark character like Jessica
Jones like knitting on the weekends or
at night when I can it really helps me
kind of like shut it down and it's just
it's very meditative and I love creating
something with my hand
who taught you my grandmother taught ago
my Grammys all right I have to be a dark
character and you can grab out there yes
thank you very much the second season of
Jessica Joe of Marvel's Jessica Jones
begins streaming on Netflix tomorrow